une production du studio sf
bio sans fil le podcast on parle de ce
qu'on veut nous invite les dates c'est
super quand tu es avec moi donne blanche
[Musique]
c'est le baiser pour moi pour nous de
recevoir 2 millions antonio qui font du
sport mondial de la batterie drôme a
fait qu'ils aient kit musicienne qui
fait le même métier que moi qui fais des
choix un peu partout à travers le québec
fait beaucoup de choses avec des
artistes avec les chocos repos toutes
sortes d'affaires et qui maintenant blow
complètement 18 réseaux sociaux sur
instagram sur techtoc savoie a fait
depuis la pandémie vraiment bien fait
des vidéos chez elle c'est vraiment de
la qualité ce qu'a fait alors une
énergie une vibe incroyable elle est
super cool c'est le ont une vraie
conversation je pense que vous allez
messieurs on plonge un petit peu dit
dans la vie de musicien dans aussi où
est-ce qu'on est rendu à nos carrières
des grands questionnements de la vie
comme on fait tout le temps alors merci
des nouveaux venus mourir - tout à fait
pire écouter une des meilleures façons
d'encourager le sans-fil podcast c'est
de s'abonner à 9 h p tu es sommes sur
notre page culture nous avez accès à
tous les podcasts contourne hostoak sont
tournés et vous avez aussi accès à au
podcast exclusif encore moins de films
qu'on fait après chaque enregistrement
donc si vous voulez avoir un brin 30
minutes de gazon sur les conversations
convient d'avoir allez vous abonner à
notre pétrole sinon vous remercie nos
commanditaires
le podcast est présentée par georges
d'orques failli se rechargent sharks et
les fournisseurs de dpn sais quoi mais
bn vous permet d'échanger virtuellement
votre location sur internet donc ça peut
permettre c'est maintenant une série un
film que vous savez qui est sortie si
les allées sur rien et flix aux autres
pillées pas disponibles a dit une
disponible dans votre location de
l'évoquer qui disposait mettons ailleurs
mais pas au québec sauf si tu resteras -
lolo une fois j'étais dans un autre pays
puis mois avant de l'embaucher du coup
toujours mon psy bio fils
disponibles imagine la panique que j'ai
vécu si j'avais su rechange bpn que
j'aurais pu écouter mon petit tu fais ça
marche ouais puis un vpn aussi ça sert à
naviguer sur des réseaux publics de
façon plus sécuritaire donc par exemple
si vous êtes souvent sur la route que
vous êtes dans des ouailles faille à
gauche à droite un vpn le vpn sur franck
en fait vous permettre d'être plus
sécuritaire dans votre connexion si vous
êtes un étudiant qu'elle est souvent
dans des cas free même principe sur
chaque offre une énorme promotion pour
vous si vous vous voulez l'utiliser le
code promo qu'on a c'est le sans filtre
en un mot tenez vous bien pour l'offre
qui sent bien que si vous êtes assis
rester assis si vous êtes debout assise
et vous êtes assis couché vous aussi
vous êtes dans votre voiture arrêtez
vous sur le côté que le club promo sans
filtre en un mot pour 83 % de rabais et
3 mois gratuits vacation et vous le
donne le québec pour pouvoir changer
virtuellement d'adressent et pour
pouvoir naviguer de façon plus
sécuritaire ce choc allez voir le site
dans la description de podcasts de
promesses sans fil en nommer ce chan
chan le podcast de cette semaine et
présenté par nos amis chier
mindscape
deviner nos préférés qui vient de sortir
le ultra premium collectionne qui est un
rassemblement de tout plein de produits
pour se nettoyer sentir bon s'hydrater
on a un d eux on a un body wash pour la
douche on a un deux en un shampoing
revitalisant on a un bon esprit
hydratante et un les bandes d'hommes
tout plein de photos livres du prime de
ce soir face à trois partout et puis
jamais espéré les amis comme vous avez
jamais vu quelqu'un se ce prix vous avez
jamais vu quelqu'un se recopier
maintenant j'ai la peau hydratée je me
sens bien et tous les produits
inscriptions lol je les ai tous essayé
c'est la même audace incroyable dans
leurs produits le shampooing conditioner
le body wash alors médecin à votre
douche et vous êtes sur des preuves de
sentir bon d'être d'être optimal pour
une vie a dit non à quoi je pense c'est
sans filtre 20% de rabais sur eux et le
shipping gratuit le shipping gratuit sur
cette collection l'eau et sur n'importe
quel produit magnifique ne soit le
package 4.0 une fausse mood package
alors allez prenez sur leur site et fait
1000 commandes lot et vous passez
commande mindscape je pense vous serez
pas déçus guest
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça roule merci d'être le cerveau des
dominos terra d'une star des réseaux
sociaux les mots les mots et les gros
mots mais c'est vrai c'est vrai ce et
ils ont le lion et moi toi tu as
commencé
à être active ses réseaux sociaux mais
plus maintenant avec tik tok tout au
début de la pandémie one way
toujours
est-ce que tu savais est ce que tu as à
100 ou genre t'as juste eu la drôle de
truc ouais c'est non je ne savais pas
pantoute c'est vraiment un drôle da don
pourrait la ville envoyer
un message de
jeu survient en plus la nuit j'ai fait
griller des toasts puis avait la vierge
marie ce midi je voulais pas les
mails f67 pose de la première vidéo puis
ça explosera direct
je pense que j'en ai comme publié
jeudi deux jours avant ce que je jouais
pas de bromont
du coup j'en joue aujourd'hui demain et
mathis tu es comme nation qu'il fallait
faire des signes avec team et je me
rappelle même pas écouté très incorrect
orageux très partagés je les vis que je
les fait celle là
dans ma tête sic texte est comme la
plate forme que je passais avec une tour
si j'avais genre 200 à venir me disait
c'était pour regarder des vidéos de chip
chip très dans le détachement pied le
non engagement que finalement il y avait
une traîne de
shaqiri
mixtape don't lie plus grandes fans de
shakira du secondaire que je suis je me
suis blessé après j'essaie de drôles que
je me fie uniquement celle là j'ai du
temps cet après-midi de faire un parking
secondes je n'avais jamais fait ça avant
ça j'avais fait des vidéos youtube
quelques quelques-uns mais prêt comme
éparpillés ceux parus dans le chaos mais
il est vrai est mandaté par manque de
temps manque de confiance ben ouais
ouais t'es trop si je voyais comme paul
intérêt je me dis intelligence que c'est
vraiment pertinent quelque chose des
covered et autres drones justement cette
journée gilles est fait mais comme un
genre de désinvolte j'aimerais pour moi
j'ai publié pied j'ai juste fait mon
cell lung le pow wow et l'afld était
revenu
j'avais genre un million de vues vous
après quelques heures cinquante mille
abonnés jampy ça ça s'arrêtera pas je
pensais qu'en fait implication buggy qui
avait géré différemment un bug chez
comme impossible s'il ya une erreur ils
vont rectifier
[Rires]
différemment le lendemain après j'ai
fait mon dernier show qui ont été là
dedans après c'est bien parce que ta vie
ta job avancé fatigué alors des shows à
temps plein puis c'est comme est hélas
pas de la transition parfaite parce que
tu as commencé ce qui l'a forcé
d'arrêter les choses près tout autant
que 10 des meilleurs
je leur ai plein fille
ouais ça a été la plus belle transition
comme comme tu dis noter je pense que
tous les élèves et les milieux
artistiques y met beaucoup plus que le
milieu artistique médecine hat on parle
des musiciens comprendre mais dans un
espèce de trou noir
est vraiment et la première semaine
c'est drôle on est en congé en plus
relax ima après ce que moi je me suis
comme rattachés à faire des vidéos sans
objectif gagner ma vie avec ça parce que
je le voyais pas le bible intérêts
demandés par je le voyais pas puis
finalement tu es aujourd'hui un an et
demi après ça va oui je me dis
principalement dessus aujourd'hui tai
chi le maintenant ça prend plus de place
dans sa vie que faute le cvu la dernière
annie des départs limites j'ai dit oui
parce que j'ai pas eu à concilier les
deux mais ce que tu retournes à faire
des choix là je recommence mais
ça semble en tout temps c'est sûr à 100
pour ça mais je sais pas si je vais
arriver comme à dormir m'attend
c'est quand même beaucoup
d'engagement d'une part au lieu de
partir cinq six heures maintenant je
peux voir un conteneur à faire du
shopping à ce que peuvent faire ma tante
à production vidéo pendant ce temps
réflexive une bonne organisation je
pense que ça va prendre mais aussi
d'être décidé quel con tre que je prends
d'abord où d'autres l'étaient tout
autant de dettes sur les réseaux sociaux
qui est
ni tournée des m'explique d'arrêt parce
que tu fais la tournée je fais aussi pie
ix où c'est un trip kiki impossible à
remplacer un trip de gang incroyable
expérience puisse y avoir le contact
avec le monde directement je dis rien
qui vaut ce nom mais sa vie avec tout un
côté de énormément perte de temps
d'attentes de choc l'hôte de la guérite
il ya un gros côté la majorité du temps
c'est zéro clameur city s'était pas en
train de renier sur le stage la majorité
du temps mais non ça c'est la véritable
star en tournée finalement tu joues la
musique et un jour normal
est étrangement brins de gazon oui parce
que la majorité du temps c'est toi qui
checke la carte dans un holiday ou d'un
peu crasseux
mais c'est du déjà vu ouais hein tandis
qu'elle est de pouvoir gagner ta vie en
état chez vous en faisant attendre à
quelques individus un petit pyrénéen
doit de routine n'est si klose de feu
n'a pas vraiment fait avancer c'est
drôle mais avant c'est comme si je
dépends des de beaucoup de personnes et
de l'expérience à mon sens les pilotes
oui c'est sûr qu'on est quand même
dépendant aux réseaux sociaux veut pas
s'arrêter du jour au lendemain mais il
ya quand même une genre de propre
business à moi qui est très différente
de conjuguer seulement pigiste batteuse
pour différents artistes différents
projets et comme de quoi qui chantent
encore plus autonome que ce que j'étais
à vendre ses souvenirs beyou t on à un
stress toujours en tant qu'artiste en
général c'est qu'est-ce qui va revivre
ce qu'on veut pas rappelé que c'est ce
qu'on va avoir un mois 2 aucune rentrée
où certains moments extraordinaires on
ne sait jamais je dis mon revenu mensuel
il varie tellement ça fonctionne pas
comme si on peut aller plus annuels mais
c'est très difficile de prévoir des
packs wii est rarement qui est à
s'arrêter quand même une genre de
révélation pour moi de pouvoir vivre de
ma passion mais toutes sortes et comme
de développement autonome d'un mode de
ton horreur exactement exactement mais
ça remplacera jamais tu veux d'essai
pour moi faire un bilan record devant
une salle remplie de gens si
indescriptible et le sentiment qu'elle
s'en donne pile énergique et je suis
booster pour
mais ouais moi la pandémie ça motive
comme toi je tombais ya pu rien à noter
enfin qu'un chaude c'est puis c'était
vraiment l'élève qui était mon activité
principale vraiment vraiment mais je
t'en fait un petit studio un peu de
réalisations plus de mixité au travail
c'est tout le temps comme kim j'ai
l'impression que je fais tout pour à 100
% ou c'est tout mais le de tomber comme
le juge juste en maintenant tout le
temps puis je peux juste vraiment me
concentrer là dessus sur la probité ben
je tripe sauf que c'est ça ma fac et toi
c'est beau c'est devenu mon mon truc
principal de mettre faire la réal mais
je me dis ah si j'étais je sais ça il
manquerait quelque chose mais c'est
l'oeuf avant d'en faire de quoi qui
tenta vidéo est postée à reste le tessin
ce qui cause a été créé quelque chose
que tu apprécies tu qu'ils ont pu
rejoindre en plus large que juste le
monde qui est le way qui permanente
parce qu'un show c'est sa beauté mais
c'est aussi le truc qui est fait main
qui dommage c'est que c'est éphémère si
tu étais le téléphone mais ça ça passe
assez mal c'est fini ouais c'est vrai
c'est vrai mayette ya de quoi tu vois
que moi ça me ça me stresse et de
justement publié une vidéo qui restent
oui contrairement faire un show que je
m'attendais à des soirées puis autre que
d'autres mais c'est passé tu l'as vécu
pire garde alors que de fait est oublié
ses fils
[Rires]
la drôme buzz en arrière
contrairement maintenant c'est
honnêtement il n'ya jamais une vidéo que
je tape à 100% je pense pas que ça va
arriver parce que je suis gamin du cians
var moi même je pense qu on l'est tous
beaucoup dans la vie de quad du fait de
deux publics qui laissent le public et
les gens y vont pour l'enregistrer ils
ont le même site la rusty terminé tic
qu'il ya de quoi qui me stresser mais
que je trouve ça aussi tellement
en fait ça m'a fait grandir ça a été
vraiment de formateurs pour moi c'est
vraiment un gros exercice
la paix au début oui autant comme je
vois en fait que ça a une incidence
autant son hyper forage maintenant que
je fais ça vraiment comme affecté en
général comment ce que je vois les
choses puis le détachement d'arrêté de
si je les fais encore un peut on
s'entendre s'ils commettent un travail
une vie non pas sur un an et demi
seulement mais je pense que ça m'a quand
même vraiment beaucoup aidé pierre oui
c'est ce que vous pensez on aurait dû
demander qu'on leur soumet ce que vous
pensez que
daniel bélanger écoute détourne de rêver
mieux qui fait genre masculin
j'aurais fait sûr je souhaite donc chaud
aux yeux ou saas est une erreur c est ce
que vous pensez que c'est parce que moi
parce que on dirait que plus on vieillit
plus je réalise que ce qu'on fait au
final est toujours imparfait de notre un
peu comme tu viens d'alerter genre fait
probablement que si le même aussi pour
seulement loti qui ont comme t on les
voit tellement mais au final
il était était jeune quand même quand il
fait le pitre et on pense que toutes les
décisions tout les trucs on saura ses
calculs 100%
je les vois des deux sens et je pense
qu'il aurait sûrement qu'on québec que
je peux parler pour lui ce moment il ya
peut-être un petit quelque chose qui va
déranger moi même temps il faut aussi
cette magie le quartier matonge ryan en
première vidéo piccini permettant aux
passagers la riposte réel est à ce point
le parquet s'ils sont mon cellulaire un
drame intéressante si lentement
la crise a aucun banc à l'image tout est
ici comme c'est zéro ce que
george aurait publié par l'ong cité
comme s'ils considèrent messages de l'au
delà que j'ai juste laisser aller si je
l'avais fait peut-être de façon plus les
schémas ton plus bas justement si
j'avais été plus pointilleuses s'était
jamais eu cette magie l'enfer qui
complètement fou à quel titre le poster
parce que derrière travailler ce truc là
tu leur est posée 2 octobre 2 octobre
peut-être quelqu'un qu'elle a fait des
conneries mais peut-être que
l'algorithme ne répond plus et la même
façon puis peut-être que tout aurait été
de ce fait c'est quand même une question
de momentum des fois d'être tous les
sens et des villes j'écoutais au jour
une série documentaire et
rick rubin qui est un réalisateur ils
sont juste les deux enfants l'art un
studio qui écoute des taux débiteurs
depuis lyon les tracks est acclamé ton
idole le drame il abaisse piloyan par le
cpie puis triple plusieurs fois jusqu'à
ma faute
mais les ya cru que la toon boom à
guitar gently weeps
qui
isole mettons grand prix baissent
ensemble c'est vraiment comme un peu
creux témoin clé ils mettent leur est
l'accompagnement psy ligue et on foule
clean paul bell et pizza comme s'il ya
deux choses qui se passent en même tant
pis le wiki paris pas de la langue de
bois pendant qu'annie dit aurait engagé
un bassiste professionnels ti qui aurait
jamais joué ce que tu fous là dessus
puis ensuite de quoi vraiment plus clean
comme en plus comme dans l'esprit un peu
du terreau est l'accompagnement dans
l'esprit de la toune qui ai dit tu vois
que mes carnets le idiote et puis lui
très petit ces malades est un fait sopi
si vous êtes
pas tant voulu le pit et comme dans le
présent mais ont craqué confort est
spartiate
c'était comme une erreur mais finalement
c'est comme on écoute ce et 50 habitants
parfait et m'a lancé jenny
frontalement ouais c'est valable le les
vieilles tu as comme ce qui existe
encore un monologue c'est dans le fond
les bobines sondage ils sont dix existe
encore le titre on peut on peut écouter
une traque solo d'1 de john lennon
chantal et je pense que c'est quoi le
studio les nils et à saint-adrien
s'appelle pilou pilou
charlie day où c'est plus un malade est
incroyable
puis l'enfant lui deux studios lenny
pied fait ainsi qu'au marché l'église du
village puis fait un gros studio danse
et ramallah puis des studios de cinéma
pine musée quand que c'est vraiment pu
lui il ya un de ses amis qui est le gars
qui a mixé
le show l'offre de
[Musique]
soleil qui est un show avec sur la
musique des beatles puis dans le fossé
mexico marc 5.1 fait que dans le fond
puis lui comme données api lutins bleus
les traqueurs fac lyon s'est assis dans
l'espèce des régies avec les kits 5.1
genre eye-fi incroyable écoute il mixe
de la musique de l'offre en pouvant
justement isolé écouter juste lit les
vocal paul mccartney ou john lennon dans
ce lot de cépie écouter juste la drogue
écoutez justel speaker à droite tant
dans les guides se promener autour de
toi puis ces gens dont on avait toutes
les larmes aux yeux maintenant c'est
clair j'aime les beatles métier je suis
pas dans l'ordre en débitant mais
j'avais quand même la mode aujourd'hui
si tu as l'impression
d'être là et de pouvoir quand même c'est
incroyable
trois chats la pile ou
une vidéo sur youtube c'est un peu
penser les larmes aux yeux le c'est
ouais ouais ouais en crise
ce type c'est asic écoute il écoute la
seule autre aquarelle sur crazy très
isolés il fait juste plus
[Rires]
souvent les way des voix la musique si
ça t'amène à déplacer c'est vrai
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui est qui 4-4
commencé de même que le tout se passe
plutôt comme un succès instantané
qu'est-ce qu'ils quittent eux remarqué
qu'elle changeait en premier et on ta ta
ta vie évidemment le avec laquelle la
pandémie on en a parlé arrête de faire
des shows média tu mets ton âme et tu
reçois un premier une première demande
de collaboration
de l'argent fort avec ce oui merci est
vraiment comme ça que ça s'est passé
pour s à peu temple
avec thomann si un distributeur
d'équipements de musique européen ce
jour le plus gros en fait c'est comme
comparer vos genre de longuè longuè quoi
il me suis heureux complet qui encore à
ce jour en fait je collabore avec hull
et ses jardins jordanie de youtube à
chaque deux semaines si ça doit faire
comme un an et demi et a alors fait une
vidéo youtube hd mais à chaque deux
semaines pour leur chaîne a eu on veut
pas rentrer bétail mais c'est comme un
bourbier
ouais c'est ça j'ai quand même beaucoup
de vidéos comme ça que c'est pas
nécessairement sur
cela
parce que tu publiquement des réseaux
sociaux directement exactement mais ça a
été mon mon premier contre qui j'ai pas
nier mon deux minutes quand je me suis
rendu compte que c'était beaucoup plus
pudique que 20 jours de show de 8 points
ç'a vraiment été seulement monde et
cliquetis rdpc moi je me trompais
français mais
[Rires]
comme si c'est quoi ça des joutes et
puis finalement je me suis dit je vais
leur demander aux questions en tête
c'est juste pour voir tes puis
finalement c'est comme la aujourd'hui tu
vois c'est rendu un petit peu plus que
ça mais à ce moment l'oeuvre comme un
ennemi l'egypte animons des minutes de
l'accident ouais ok qu'acheter un qui a
king pour être chez moi faire un cover
une toune décryptage en 25
ans même s'ils gagnent 10 semaines j'ai
fait un choc était
72,5 en bonne santé mais j'ai tellement
de plaisir mais tout ça pour vous étiez
l'argent
tandis que
dehors de tout mandat ni comment un
barème en tant que mécanicien qui fait
qu'on peut demander plus que c'est comme
malvy s'est clos mais pour qui tu parles
on va en trouver un emploi c'est un
musicien plein musique et paul l'acte
justement 105e commencera pas demander
plus cher que l'auteur compositeur
interprète
c'est quand même fou parce que tous les
musiciens en général on est derrière y'a
pas comme un petit spot lights ou
une formation comme ça qui est pigiste
pour faire jaillir artiste tu fais ta
job du feu depuis la city mais pour moi
ça a vraiment changé beaucoup que c'est
le jjda sentiment d'imposture
collins six mois qui est en avance sur
les réseaux plus moi même sommes voire
moins que je dis donc ça m'a vraiment ce
que vous dites petit charles pic et une
en moi quelque chose de ce qui est un
instrument accompagnateurs je n'aime pas
me l'a dit
qui aimait ses hôtes puis j'ai apprécié
en plus que les gens qui te suivent
c'est pas juste des drames au ralenti
non vraiment et je mettais sur twitter
en ce moment je pense que comme un
million lorsque j'ai capté 2 millions
cette semaine ses créations c'est pas
vrai que ces millions de drams a
massivement quitté km ce devoir jouer du
drame même quand même foot et puis
vraiment deux mondes qui évoquait
l'intérêt pour le grand mavs
vraiment il ya énormément de personnes
qui me disent toute ma vie m'a t'on j'ai
vu les jurys du breuil disais que
c'était pas passer n'importe qui puisse
me donne envie d'aller m'acheter un
drame puis pour vrai j'en reçois tous
les jours alors vraiment beaucoup des
messages comme cet
iphone
qu'est ce qui fait son succès c'est que
tu réussis je te mérite pas d'être dans
tout le truc
non mais la science qui j'imagine que tu
consommes quand même tectoniques connaît
mollicone maintenant de huit mois je
suis aussi qu'est-ce-qui qu'est ce qui
marche petit souci c'est que les
nouvelles tonnes qui sortent les
facteurs tally
justement les codes détecteur puis les
toons qui marche vraiment hâte à patient
quel drame soit il et d'un ensemble
c'est comme ça c'est ce qui fait que ça
irait mais avant j'ai steve est beaucoup
plus et je n'aime pas j'avais beaucoup
plus du temps c'est comme avant mais ton
que j'arrête mes premiers contrats de
plus en plus il agit je me concentrais
vraiment essayer justement d'être
transformés ni john sur le drone s'est
vu des beignets avril et et j'ai fait
les affaires de 6 à 25 ce genre de faire
tomber tes lunettes on entend un master
en gentil legging thèmes en scène ce que
je ferai le 10 mai des affaires comme ça
quand même pied soit le jeu les six de
moins en moins qui je fais plus comme
une demande spéciale c'est plus sûr
c'est quand que je vois qui est vraiment
comme
d'habitude aux cadres et avancer une
nouvelle tenue je vais la faire c'est
une des mes temps pour l'halloween une
thune ses jardins et elle a besoin de
faire plus que jouer une toune pis tout
temps en temps je prends rien pour
acquis oui je pense que c'était
tellement des vagues tout autant qui est
des fois je publie des trucs qui
marchent 0 puis je prends pas
personnellement dany c'est une question
dargaud rythme au sipi de
6 à 10 que les réseaux sociaux veulent
pousser ya défendu d'eau qui va super
bien marché sur instagram 0 sur tik tok
puis l'inversé c'est comme un peu une
science qui en fait le seul non vraiment
on prend vraiment vraiment un peu
inquiète et on s'est dit tiens code jam
à bassorah entrer un code on sait que ça
va marcher et
en plus c'est que ces affaires le
rapport qui est sorti sur facebook alain
terme comme la leur algorithme avait été
programmée initialement dit il disait
que le caillou me libre c'était plus
justin koumba pts avait aussi plaidé les
bonhommes qui réagissait maintenant
qu'un bonhomme qui réagissait fâché avec
dix fois plus de poids dans la galerie
qu'un like
permettons il se doit qui ça poussait
dans le fond tout ce qui était très
controversé ou qui rendait le mandant
christi texas avait dix fois plus
d'impact dans un post comment
l'algorithme à l'analyse qu'en fait
quand tu vois à faire eux-mêmes tu dis
je vois pas me casser la tête pour
essayer de comprendre comment ça marche
parce qu'il ya trop de facteurs qui sont
hors de notre contrôle qui changent tout
le temps qu'on le sait juste pour loin
annoncé fois j'entends mme emilienne
théorie pied pour le rendu loti je pense
pas qu'on peu comme essayer de créer une
formule exacte y'en a pas
de formules exactement après
le dos des ça marche par exemple sur
youtube ou
[Rires]
encore
toute évidence à regarder partout
imagine que tu vois tes youtube plus aux
states que si ça l'est pas vraiment des
raisons techniques pas les gens me
disent on est elle-même qui tire surtout
depuis que non parce que si évidemment
pas les mêmes pourcentages des pays plus
pourrais je vivre peut faire avec ce que
je regarde ses statistiques le mans
c'est pas les mêmes pays selon les
réseaux sociaux aqesss c'est j'imagine
que quand quelque chose y est virale sur
une plate forme et qui sert partager ça
va des fois justement aller dans entre
annie qui est dans une certaine région
par rapport fait que ça fait en sorte
que ces primes
c'est un peu ça
inexpiable une chanson qui vient plus
que j'en ai un
écossais
détecteur que ça a fait ça parce que il
ya tellement d affaires qui sont devenus
ti la viralité le qui sont devenu viral
mais d'une façon complètement
inexplicable dépoter le gars qui fait du
longboard avec la 32x révélé trop de mal
à cela c'est inexplicable levé il ya
genre c'est un combo d'un million
d'affaires là tous une bonne tourner
mais ce point de nouvelles tendances et
la connaissait avant que ça sert à ça
sort le gueulard smoothies couilles
boîte jusqu'à l'hiver tu sais c'est quoi
la barre vraiment que fellah la tempête
parfaite pour que ça explose
mondialement mois ce matin je prenais un
guest piste de glace et sa vibe c'est
seulement une question de vice en
général c'est je vais pas à 100% à cause
de ça mais j'ai l'impression mettons
pour ma part mes vidéos c'est beaucoup
par rapport à comment j'ai du fun même
ces gens ils s'en foutent du groupe
comme de quoi qui sait qu'ils trouvent
leur compte j'ai 100 regardant comme ma
passion de t'être fait que gérer mathon
ces gars-là c'est régis d un côté de gym
à
100% en plus de gueule la journée
c'était cela le post initial c'était ce
qu'ils disent est ce texte son show ils
partent son char pour aller à sa job le
char pas partie il est en retard pour sa
job que la place de tabarnak qui a fait
j'ai décidé de vibe et leur gueule il
prend son envol plus faibles tiff
hectares et sombre allemands qui ont
foutu le genre de mon âme saut à skis
ski les skis les appareils qui les rend
heureux de taille qui laisse l'ordre
lors leurs troubles ailleurs s'est
peut-être
laissé passer
jusqu'à
demain qui s'appelle le drummer de fuite
ou de mac ne sais pas ce sera magna lui
même gens chantent l'outaouais aux
incroyables
mais ça c'est fou avec tik tok commun
que ça rejoint moi je trouve que ce qui
est débile c'est que ça enlève un peu
là-bas hier entre on va dire les madame
tout le monde et les artistes il ya
comme de quoi que ça comme une
communauté qui se développe ses portes
si justement tu es un dieu qui fait du
longboard la drôme où justement il veut
il
était dans les buvettes jus de
canneberge aussi en répondant je crois
même si y'a de quoi qu'il en soit qui
est un truc de communauté qui strict
pour pour vrai moi j'ai clairement un
des côtés hyper positif des tic tac tic
il y en a comme toute chose dans cette
impasse mais seul je trouve qu'il ya
vraiment de quoi
vraiment compliqué pour moi chaque fois
qu'un artiste ma réponse quelque chose
je capte ce à chaque fois que je mets en
voyant des artistes de tout ce que tu
fais ce que j'ai fait ce que je pensais
en ski que de reporter
sine die de riposte situe la chose la
plus
facile vertige deux fois déjà à quel
point ça
si ça parce que j'ai commencé à faire du
drame a beaucoup d'amis qui
jouait jeudi des rumeurs font par pure
passion ici un jour je peux jouer avec
harbin importe que mes amis j'ai de la
fille la plus réussie de voir ma tante
et on a tout se règle en interne à cette
demande que c'est quand même de voir des
plus gros chaude aux artistes qui
donnent son pied pour vraiment ça me
fait capoter le lait commencent que ça
rejoint des fautes mais en voyant mon
sujet je souhaite en commun d'une tonne
derrière dans ma cour je vais rater
kuyssche ping averti j'ai parlé avec
nicolas technique tpiy j'ai une équipe
jeune et sympathique pilote j'ai quitté
d'affaires puis mike portnoy qui
comme
les gens vont se courir dans cette
jungle
pas nécessairement voir qu'ils étaient
amis ou peu importe mais surtout tu vois
qu'ils étaient amis
des fois je peux demander minute quand
je m'attends j'étais ami avec papa roach
avec des affaires de match com
ouais mais ce que j'ai vu c'est fait
aussi de la chaîne youtube
johnny oui mes chiens affiche qui fait
partie de leurs dix coach a qu'à chaque
semaine depuis que ça va faire un an que
je fais dit lifestream pour une heure
par semaine dans mon studio enfants
pourraient se pourrait
[Rires]
qu'en dit ouais j'ai commencé
officiellement et enfin secondaire matte
ont failli plus sérieusement mettons à à
15 16 ans ans et jouait du violon
concentration musique et joseph françois
perrault à montréal et j'ai quand même
été
gracié cette percussion classique ou
vial ont fait que j'ai pris alors ça
fait comme poggio et d'yttrium une fois
de temps en temps le temps mais j'ai
découvert que c'était exactement mais à
mon père était batteur aussi gagner sa
vie comme ça quand même pendant un bon
moment factice c'est sûr que jamais
l'homme à quelque part dans ma tête oui
s'il s'agit que la chance d'être élevés
quand même avec une famille de musiciens
comme un studio chez moi quand même aidé
à mon développement avant le drame mais
ouais j'ai combien un virement
d'instruments genre contre 4,5 que j'ai
dit à mes parents je m'en vais au cégep
pandorum déjà presque pas joué diderot
m'ont pas aidé un homme abattu
six mamans éléphants si je vous dis ça a
commencé comme ça craque mais non ça
faisait ça faisait deux ans que je le
pensais j'aurais
sûrement un peu vite mais si les faits
aussi d'avoir une bonne base en classe
et si c'est tellement comme deux autres
pour signer mais il ya quand même de
quoi si complémentaires commun c'est
qu'ils me m'a vraiment aidé dans le
programme en instrument qui qui peut
t'emmener dit que non plus mais y est
quoi qui s'est bâti leur vie fondements
de la musique que tous les instruments
ou l'autre
langage le rythme et une foutue le
comprends c'est de retrouver
physiquement comment les sous ma
fonction c'est déjà par ses maîtres
tests avaient déjà le sens du terme
[Musique]
au complet a précisé après ça j'ai fait
un bac en communication ah ouais ouais
donc t'as pas fait leur style m non j'ai
en fait je gagne bien ma vie en faisant
la musique j'ai comme des cités pas
poursuivre mes études
pour avoir un jour des plans b donc
piste est quelque chose qui me
passionnait beaucoup la communication en
général les graphistes ou fac j'ai je me
suis juste se développer d'autres
connaissances connecte à la musique
quand même parce que c'est très très
rare lippi gp2
au niveau de la promotion et n'en
énormément et j'ai déjà un artiste pour
que ça ça puisse réussir quand même un
immense côté promotionnel qui doit être
présente mutationnelles ne serait-ce que
le côté pierre et si ce chiffre
la connexion
c'est vraiment 7 puis finalement je me
suis retrouvé à faire des pochettes
d'albums des sites web comme kit presse
dommage j'ai fait vraiment tout c'est
pour plusieurs artistes avec qui
je savais que j'en étais capable c'est
quand tabarnak avant
on a besoin d'un orque puis d'un
communiqué de presse
et à des dédommagements d'un match après
match ouais je
voulais
[Rires]
quand ça faire des bacs pigeard après
l'ajout de la baisse un tel mode dans
lequel comme je vois tu indispensable du
propos mme brown je comprends d'affaires
par des bacs aussi pour ce geste de
gamme percussions bacqué séquence a
besoin de violon
des années
70 avant mais non non ce geste ap seul
le renvoi
c'était quoi le mettons les
constructeurs y mettons
chronologiquement maintenant les plus
les plus importants le trim et ont
exhorté ceux qui te jouer ou tv et moi
je vais j'essaie de recréer cela mais
maintenant j'ai commencé à faire des
choix forcément au cégep gens ma
deuxième année j'étais engagé pour faire
des shows corpo vraiment produit dans
les bars d'un casino j'en ai fait trop
[Rires]
la pandémie que mis un terme à ce débat
que j'ai dit et ce qu'on pense à lui mis
un terme à oui ça très longtemps qu'un
effet
normalement les packs a study faut que
j'explique un peu utile qu'est ce que
c'est
complètement métier mettons pour les
gens qui écoutent donc une déco qu'on
parle 6,6 et des shows mettons qu'on son
mariage soit dans les bars ou soit dans
des
bureaux beaucoup sait où est ce que on
arrive là puis on joue 2h et 3h des
musiques de covered et des plus grands
et des années 60 à aujourd'hui
exactement un grossiste etc puis la set
list change pas tant que ça dans le show
à l'autre c'est tout le temps plein
contre les merlus sont différents et si
comme tout le temps les mêmes tourner
c'est un peu la même un brin set mais
c'est aussi quelqu'un qui part à will
survive le monde des capotes
série gp2 cités s'ils font défaut à 10h
au prince haïti des sorties des sorties
là dessus que la femme c'est comme dans
le monde ils veulent à wall street c'est
certes pas trop sortir
malheureusement non non non ça c'est des
gens n'est pas qu'une kings
je t'avais par les groupes partagent
avait parlé du dugas qui que j'avais
pris sur un mégot express qui avait un
bel hommage à bethel qp méga d'être mise
à jour les b-sens
red skull harnais dit planer un cholet
on ne s'était pas rendu à cette manne
pièces ici sur le monde ont tripé le
plus c'est comme que je pense
c'est que mais c'était quand même
insulté quand au sénat ne l'émeut le
monde très plus qu une fois kington que
personne n'a entendu c'est le capot nous
parlons
c'est comme jane fonda qui avait
endommagé les à plein
j'allais chez eux
[Rires]
j'ai commencé début
puis avec des amis du chemin du cégep
université de comment faire au
début tu ns autre
témoin j'avais pas moi mettons sur l'art
je faisais pas tant de musique le
transport est tout de même c'est
seulement comme un autre monde ggf et
des cours de piano un peu j'avais des
cours de guitare c'est le soir le team
et je n'ai pas sérieux puisque on
commence par 5,7 après que la musique ça
m'intéresse logicom m'exprime mieux
préparés puis c'est vraiment comme ça
j'ai commencé à être sérieux mais bref
c'est au début on était j'aurais piétine
d'autres mines québec le supplia québec
qui est quand même vraiment beaucoup de
bord puis de deux classes et la musique
la danse et des bennes de temps fort
et juste est tellement tu h à québec à
québec et dans dans mes débuts le
synology en face à tant être croire que
je n'avais pas c'est quoi les
coins ce test d'un rien un coin et elle
l'a placé
au
mercato c'est même rappelé jane place
est quand même j'en mythique est le
backgammon non
non
on va sur le cours bas qui suit à
gavanon
boulot j'ai en face en face dans une
place
masséna entend j'avais à peine deux
filles
non ça c'est après cela j'étais engagé
justement pour tout de suite j'ai
justement évidemment bénéfique
à main et petit pont de sambre l'asim
est
bénéfique dans en a fait un spectateur
d'agde je pense que oui je pense que ce
terreau d'agde ouais et comme nous avec
ta main c'est exactement ce qui lui
convenait tous de montréal ils ont les
gilles bouleau j'en passe wiltord face
non si j'arrête de genre l'apartheid la
part de google wave the way we
montarville à vous de faire le ménage la
vie mais
j'ai traîné la réputation
exactement lingual rue mais
j'ai comme poser la question est aussi
en fait avait déjà joué les piquets
japon tabitha
littéralement côté annoncé ça mais bref
tout ça pour dire j'ai jamais vu un
appart ou h comme ceux en qui on n'a pas
aimé je donnerai pas de détails mais tu
m'attends dans l'envié
si la chanteuse est bien correct mais
c'est là on n'a pas dormi
québec faisait tourner justement débats
plus ou moins caché que cette soirée là
mais ça fait longtemps qu'on en parle ça
fait
un gros
défaut aussi le toit jonathan mariage de
mondor support reichmann dilate c'est la
démesure totale puis ces gens qui après
ce tu joue pis si nous on ne fait les
gens des petits gris nez de jonques à
qui on donnerait le
prix par le pij de
la journée tout âge encore non c'est
selon ses pieds non c'est semer
mais oui bref me lève tôt pour
10,4 comment ce
parce que cecon ses proches
qui
sont payantes et puis dites vous pas au
fil de fil en aiguille s'attache à
fait que la peur des mots ça fait
longtemps que je voulais en sortir et
que j'essayais d'en sortir mais comme
j'avais à dire non le moment piloter
comme je restais tout en l'adaptant à
paris par l'ompi le sénat c'est comme si
le centre est de repartir pis le jeu
comme est acceptée j'ai comme dit ça va
être long mais ouais
mais tu dois sûrement genre à faire des
sans pareil en exemple mais
on a eu un gros tacle plus légers comme
faites moi un truc je puis le canada
métier c'est pas facile parce que veut
pas aussi stats
hcc c'est une sécurité aussi mais oui
clairement pour moi ce qui m'a fait
sortir
ils pourraient jeudi sortie mais c'est
juste parce que les les je peux dire que
c'est quand même assez rohff sur ta
santé en général parce que moi je me
rappelle juste à m'embêter je vais
continuer mon merveilleux pour ensuite
quand je suis sorti du cégep gérald vers
ce pays à temps plein depuis j'ai
commencé avec éric masson je sais pas si
vous savez ce qu'ils chantent animé qui
quand même assez peu peur dans les yeux
les rayons l'anodin par jour dont 10
avant la sidr j'ai mangé beaucoup dans
le coin de trophy québec chaoui tout ce
qui c'était comme un 125 shows par année
dans les bras 25
au repos
c'est beaucoup de choses ouais ouais
vraiment universités temps sur un choc
trois jours un site web qui je faisais
l'aller-retour à tout les soirs morin
québec montréal trois vies montréal à
vous de remettre toujours toujours
dormait à montréal fait que randa habib
le lever du soleil tout le temps parce
que tu fais une joie de trois artistes
de l'ordre ont fait chercher de quoi
manger ou 140
mm soit le seul sait ce que c'est en
train d'écrire c'est un cauchemar
j'ai arrêté pour cette raison que
j'avais vraiment du fun to me savais
comme peu de bon sens le des piges
étudiante sans tchèque à moitié dans un
bar derrière tu savais comme pas de bon
sens l'ait fait
j'ai arrêté ce look mais après j'ai
commencé à voir vraiment des belles
conditions quand j'ai arrêté ça a été
comme un si l'élève je pense la dernière
année vraiment que j'ai fait que corpo
bord via prè j'ai commencé vraiment joué
avec des artistes originaux c'est
vraiment que c'était des tours min puis
en salle puis beaucoup moins d'écho
repos puis de bord qui est sale et
comment ces enfants à ce moment là parce
que c'est que tout défaut faute sinon
quelque chose à y faire de la place à
which
way c'est vraiment vraiment c'est pour s
à tout un été comme ça pour moi dans ma
vie je pense à ceux la semaine dernière
j'ai un jour de l'introspection de mes
dernières années puis c'est comme si
depuis dix ans la vie même est sur mon
chemin
c'est comme si quelque chose se termine
puis tout de suite il ya quelque chose
d'autre qui arrive d'extraordinaire
puisque c'est tout le temps comme ça
tosic du beau jeu mais ça a vraiment été
c'est pour moi fait glisser comme à
chaque fois maintenant qu'une
collaboration avec un artiste et a
terminé pour x raisons parfois il y
avait tout en quelque chose d'autre qui
arrivait à l'acide fait qu'ici c'est mon
parcours au comité
ça s'enchaîne comme ça des pierres
ce que c'est vrai ce que des fois c'est
le film
[Musique]
c'est un film avec kevin costner oeuvres
d'art sont ces genres c'est qu'on le
sait vraiment qu'on le concept est
vraiment bad le sait il construit un
terrain de baseball pour que
son père qui mord viennent sur le
terrain de baseball avec des anciens
joueurs professionnels
cd aussi
la phrase c'est build it and will come
as may entend ce genre venant de l'eau
de leurs puits la morale finalement du
film c'est que des fois faut que tu
prennes action avant d'avoir la
certitude que que tu ferais quand
l'action ba qui est nécessaire mais ton
avant d'avoir le site ynet de dire ok
merci jared ce
je ne sais pas si ça va fonctionner sauf
que des fois faut que tu l'arrêtent pour
justement ouvrir comme tu viens de dire
le ouvrir la porte à d'autres à forte
c'est vraiment mais d'avoir cette
mentalité là c'est off parce que si
d'ici je veux pas être lancé dans le
vide trop souvent surtout dans un métier
comme un certain domaine artistique qui
est quand même plus difficile de cette
armée de gaieté métier je m'attends à
l'échelle du studio aussi de chez nous
on s'est dit on devrait faire ça on
n'avait aucune certitude que ça allait
fonctionner bien qu'on ait ouvert la
porte à 10 rebonds mais on le fait mais
leur les affronter tous tout et c'est
réglé par le but par soi même le nom de
ti avec des fois c'est mais c'est la
farce staples c'est vraiment difficile
surtout quand une question monétaire
séance en sentant l'aubaine bowser qu'à
l'argent c'est pas important mais c'est
quand même important c'est quand même
très important qui sait comme un peu
c'est faire des cortots
stable
oui c'est un revenu stable puis au début
si moi je me souviens qu'en que je
commence à faire ce début vingtaine
c'était beaucoup d'argent pour lui déjà
trois musiciens pour un musicien et puis
par rapport aussi mes amis qui étaient
comme encore aux études ouais je t'ai
comme moi je t'ai sur le marché du
travail déjà que je gagnais ma vie piste
incroyable mais le grec est en cours
d'étude mais mon ami fils maintenant qui
est médecin je veux me dépasser
mais
mais ce pour ce que c'est que ces coups
par un moment mais ammann et réalise
aussi qu'il ya un nombre maximal de
chaud tu peux faire dans un ami c'est
tellement certains noms maximale de ce
qui a été payé par soit aussi au maximum
avec nos ondes a été quand tu calcules
tu calcules quand même facile à faire
pipi c'est cool pour une personne dans
mon métier à long terme pour comme
construire de quoi puisque gérard une
famille pts 6e 6e ça marche plus
vraiment et pigeard moi je n'ai fait des
années la 152e sang chaud le tipi
j'entends pu parce que c'est trop dit
jean petit peut pas non plus faire ce si
tu veux avoir d'autres projets comme une
famille wever
sac amman il faut combres or penser à ce
petit tu te rends compte que le modèle
il pas sustainable pis c'est toi tel
qu on le sent que tu étais de cet esprit
entrepreneur le t2 comme qui étaient
calmes ans que je veux faire de mon or
comment je veux faire de ma personne par
business mais c'est un petit cliniciens
console en dépit moi je lis et me pigeot
rien et que c'est bien payé le tpiy il
ya un hic c'est ici la musique avant
tout mais j'ai quand même se poser la
question des com comment du conte avis
ça fait partie de dangereux puis si tu
passes pour ben ça finit par bris mais
là aussi du mois et finalement tu vas
finir par faire autre chose parce que
parce que ça peut marcher parce que tu
étais pas capable d'en vivre vraiment
puig est quoi aussi qu'elle est
tellement domitien que je rencontre qui
sont frustrés qui je les comprends en
même temps par rapport aux cours et des
geeks d'abord catus et mettons de sept
pays tant par sa pipe si tu mentes juste
un petit peu plus
- c'est ping c'est là que tu dis ça à
quel point que je mets mon pied à terre
puis que je risque de perdre ma job mais
qu'en même temps c'est une question de
principe c'est que ça c'est pas ces pays
vous aimez c'est qu'ils quittaient ce
moment donné parce que pas du tout
soi-même moi tu vois je le vois pas
comme ça que j'ai jamais vue comme ce
pied ou un jet
ski c'est ma valeur si vous payez pour
cette valeur là bas ça marche pas par
plus mais j'ai pas tout le temps été
comme ça parce qu'elle clame un pays
mais je te comprend le jeu est encore
aux études c'est vraiment ottawa comme
ghz tdp importe quand est-ce que c'est
parfois aussi mais reste quand même que
leur mandat ni quand celui-ci c'est quoi
ta valeur aussi piqué c'est en tentant
voit d'autres choses qui sont payés plus
que citer comme karim c'est pourquoi que
donc tu ne serait ce qu'un cent pièces
de différence par son ça fait une grosse
différence
mais
cette injustice ce petit jeu comprend
même tenté les restos les bordes ceux
qui n'ont pas des fois le budget
comprend 100% mais rendu justice est une
décision personnelle de est ce que mon
temps ce soir rivaux sortie si c'est
vraiment ces
deux cas pas de dire donc un carton que
ça fait pas censé y titeuf c'est le
dernier os 3 go et privés il ya un
plaisir ici c'est plaisant d'aller jouer
puis le plaisir d'aussi de peau des
savoirs ou de petits êtres mais liben
soit y en a un qui comme un peu les
rangs des pays perdre
non mais
c'est important et non c'est vraiment a
dit que laquelle il travaille il faut se
tenir c'est vrai ce que tu dis depuis le
c'est vraiment un stock de musique
mais
si on s'impose parce qu'il y en a pas
si on se tient pas au jeu dire on veut
tout le temps niveler vers le bonheur
c'est qu'ici on dit pas aussi belle pour
une toujours des geeks c'est pas un beau
dessous
c'est lui qui diomède rôle très
important ça fait ch grâce à sa descente
tout le monde en même temps je comprends
cette personne c'est que la jolie avait
exactement exacte et reconnaître puis
après ce pouvoir elles aussi modifiées
aux pcs pour se tester
au
feuilleton pieds-poings web par rapport
à ce que toi tu sais que tu vaux puis de
dakar le coup et ce sans que ceci
implique un lot de risques fous que tous
deux se garde de le prendre des fois tu
vois des preuves qu'étudie genre qui me
le demandent un salaire des les bains
pilote quatre demandes plus c'est disons
ne pas large en plus il ya un problème
quelque part c'est prochain mais c'est
un cas lequel temps d'hier
mais en même temps pour avoir été des
fois tu mets ton avec
avec mon ex qui les chanteuses on avait
un projet de le compo le tic tac une
faute on était un peu producteurs à
regarder comme des shows qu'on faisait
petit répit la réalité l'aube a aussi
des fois tu sais c'est comme le montant
des demandes pilotis s'étoffe aussi
pour tout le monde dans le fond natif
avec les fossés de ce oui on voit toute
réalité par était la face est du moment
qu'ils étaient contents mettant des
conditions peu te moi j'ai toujours dit
ce même si je suis voit que ce soit cinq
fois dans le monde que normalement si tu
es content quand même des conditions à
ce moment là s'ils savent le risque pris
par par la personne qui paye mais oui
c'est cet effet si je pense qu'on
comprend quand même qu'on a juste montré
content qu'on ait pas indispensable
puisque s'il ya un salaire qui convient
à semer que c'est pas non plus tous les
profits qu'ils nous reviennent quand
même mais les pertes non plus faut pas
que ça nous a
légué galles archibald finalement le
lâche balle dans le trou parce que parce
qu'ils ont moins de clientes soirée
loupe qu'il faut que l'austère plus le
band tout un côté plus exactement un an
exactement mais était jeudi soumis
depuis les dernières années et je suis
vraiment déçu par belles conditions
pièce je me trouve vraiment choyé et
éjecte ont finalement participé
j'ai comme beaucoup d'artistes j'aurais
gérons actuellement ses professeurs les
montures fait beaucoup la voient
comme ma liste moyon fait lavoine et
qui après j'étais avec 130 rôles depuis
les quatre dernières a mis pied léger si
pierre laquelle jackie mittoo
voilà qui avait chez rendu pour novembre
décembre avec damien robitaille de sa
tournée de ce soir à bien ce sera l
excès novembre décembre c'est cholet qui
apprécie pour 2022 mais j'ai regardé ce
que je veux faire quelque chose et les
pièces mhsc peu comme le dire en ce
moment mais oui ce sont là des trucs
comme ça fac et moi j'aime bien quand
même faire et faire des choses que je
fais partie du hold'em dont j'aime
vraiment ça c'est très cool je vais avec
une panoplie d'artistes et ceci était
une fois en france en tant que c'est
très spontané et une fois qu'ils ont
refait plus chaud le mais y'a de quoi
que j'aimerais
quand même quand même moins tu n'attends
du gala ce cas j'ai fait toutes les
amicales evenko ya les artistes que j'ai
fait l'année chose refuge cdd chaud
comme ça ouais que c'est éphémère de te
sens tu vas prendre une seule fois mais
si
tout le monde comme aïda samba même
direction c'est ça marche comme un jour
d'excitation de stress de plus d'équité
est en tournée puisque tu connais show
en dormant mais y'a d'quoi d'un défi
plus je pense qui comme pour ma part
c'est comme nécessaires rendrait d'avoir
quelque chose comme ça dans l'année qui
me déstabilise un petit peu plus que
d'être dans des pantoufles tout le temps
moi de tout temps faire c'est la même
chose que je dois m'habituer puis en
même temps si ce genre de show le qui
m'a permis de développer une plus grande
confiance dans mon instrument les shows
que je connaissais à 100% sa majesté
juste comme plus mais développés pma
reste dans mon instrument lui chose que
quand ils font un choc engagé pour une
seule fois tic doit être dans les temps
la church quai sur check et de kew du
directeur musical tout le sud - seront
100% très haut niveau prestance scénique
confiant au petit chien guillemets
contre le corpo hôpitaux mais non moins
semeta moi c'est la chose qui a fait que
je fais cela dit aujourd'hui que
j'arrive sur un choc quand j'arrive sur
scène ça marche le fesf qui au début les
premières fois ça ne va pas marcher tant
que ça n'a rien avoir fait des centaines
d'adhérents j'ai pas ça qui se mettront
j'avais dit à moi je veux je peux faire
de corpeau dans ma vie mais ton ou des
au début puis je juge sur les artistes
je sais pas si je me serais rendu
si j'aurais panis présence sur scène
comme si une bonne école par plus tu
fais souvent c'est dans l'ombre un peu
dans ce sens qu'un policier qui sont là
pour que j'étais souvent temps quand il
fait ses apports le monde et qui tu
joues et y apporte ici pas sous les
projecteurs mais tant que tu apprécies
tu arrives sur des shows des artistes
plus
tu as raison je pense que pour moi c'est
quand j'ai dit mettons que je parlais à
l'université en musique nous ne céderons
ma deuxième école ça allait vraiment été
de faire des shows thé mais voudrait
aimanté corpo justement t on ici qu'au
repos même si ça reste un show pareil
rc6 pour moi ça qui est la chose qui m'a
le plus fort mais clairement pid qui a
développé mon répertoire aussi à un
point très extrêmes le titre je pense
que tu connais beaucoup tourner mais il
y en a quand même tout le temps à
prendre et puis ça m'a vraiment former
puis l'endurance la part des choses et 3
4 heures non stop plusieurs soirs
d'affilée tout y est comme de quoi qui
est tu peux pas prendre ça autrement que
d'élever mais oui c'est souvent imputés
au moment où tu arrives ledit poste qu'à
ta vie des autres qui re juste avait pas
toutes ces choses là derrière la cravate
josé serpa aux lieux effectué une passe
pour arrive puis ça paraît que c'est
solide ça paraît que fait ce pardon des
années tout ça par exemple un énorme
moi c'est ça ça a toujours la façon
comment choisis-tu tonne m c'est si
c'est vraiment un melting-pot de plaine
en faire mais comme les demandes
spéciales clairement si j'ai des
demandes vraiment des compagnies ou si
l'oeil en aliments que ça étonne tant
pis fixe non moins les tourner que
j'aime
leach m
ça ressemble comme peu mal assumée pour
lé genre une liste d'enfants mardi de
thoune potentiel à faire tu tapes
advance j'en ai dit sophia aucun bon
sens pourtant je regarde le nombre de
vidéos que j'ai publié j'en ai fait
beaucoup t on mais des tonnes des
35 albums
est-ce qu'il ya détournent des fois
qu'ils mettront tout comme un soutien
populaire plus faire c'est qu'outre la
montée petit tabac max est plus complexe
que je pensais
oui ça va ça va arriver
ouais d'été il ya certainement des toons
que je passe beaucoup plus de temps à
répliquer qu'il y en a d'autres que si
vraiment fasse
vraiment mais oui il y en a certainement
tu te dois justement les plus des
classiques roi qui me tombe tout seul
c'est quand qu'il ya plus de repiquage à
faire moins drôle parce que déjà un
grand manque il participe en gestion
d'entre nous de rendre justice mais
aussi que mon planning soit le camp mais
pas exactement la même chose c'est ce
qui va avec la série a que ce soit des
plus riches et
gèle si ça me tentait juste pas de femme
et ses gosses raté 11 comme marin entre
deux âges est aussi une personnalité à
moins d'avoir le drame c'est bien
correct et toutes les cover qu'on va me
tomber les chanteurs qui chantent pas
assise non plus
les picards et ont scandé tourne trop
pop belle il n'y a pas de drame c'est
facile vaillante et s'est fixé comme
jamais tout le monde est heureux non
jamais jamais autant que sa routine
qu'elle ya personne heureuse moi ça me
va c'est vraiment tout seul à lyon je
connais sur millions par an ça
me contenter
juste une force des nombreux travaux
mais rien
c'est littéralement seul et j'essaie de
garder ce le fun parce que ça peut vite
tomber dans l'obligation pour les
autotests puis tout ça parce que pour
être avant j'allais faire mon show je
revenais j'avais pu rien à faire le tri
ben oui peut-être la pratique
personnelle tout ça mais ça restait seul
le sait comme un fini les yeux comme je
ressens quand même tout en ne demande
que haye était la fierté de tout ce que
je peux faire de ma liste infinie puis
le faut juste que je me disais qu'ils
aient si ça me tente je vais aller les
faire mais faut pas non plus que ça
devienne un fardeau tu sais ce qu'est le
tryptophane enfant s'il pleut ça va
paraître que j'étais foutu comme un
calendrier de pause je suppose tout
comme au noir récurrent touche passe pas
d'un manière et que je vais vraiment
comme ces sources si j'ai des
collaborations le ton avec norman et
compagnie est vraiment date de
publication mais pour le reste je vais
un peu comme ans que je suis au sein
puis 6,6 au g7 de publier plusieurs fois
par semaine les jeudis matins youtube
une fois par deux semaines trois
semaines j'essaie de marquer un peu par
rapport à ceux ci plus d'engagement
pillet s'occupe d'enfants la différence
c'est que tu fais une version courte du
tour c'est ce que j comme j'ai fait pas
tout parce que sinon ça j'en ferais
vraiment beaucoup sur youtube mais j'en
fais maintenant une ou deux par mois au
complet c'est moins 80 techtoc je te
souhaite une complète je fais beaucoup
juste la bonne voie que tu dois juste le
but puis des fois j'essaie de créer une
loupe pas que dame c'est parce que entre
autres choses que toute sa joie en
lipides d'enfanter pas besoin de reposer
sur playmate enquête c'est comme youtube
tout ce que je voulais que ce mandat
j'ai failli mourir je te regarde et je
dors
si ses envies de titre
mais non si c'est j'aime faire un temps
la loupe qui est des fois pas
l'impression mettons que la vidéo oui si
tu supportes attention selon kevin
peut-être pas au même endroit les gens
c'est à s'y méprendre qui vont la
regarder une deuxième fois cinq six fois
plus et les 15 secondes après le
[Rires]
wi fi et on attend ça peut prendre enfin
le temps est plus fort maintenant pour
la voix
met en vidéo youtube qui maintenant
quand je commence avec ses deux take 2 3
tech dieu c'est fini tu as fais mon
maximum c'est comme un renégat avec mon
caméraman ont dit tout le temps la
troisième c'est la bonne que la dernière
fois les deux dans l'info ça a été les
deuxièmes fait se protéger des deux mois
puis c'est un plan séquence je fais pas
des deux trains c'est vraiment comme ça
les gens agissent par ce qui est une
question de deux temps puis aussi le
fait qu'il y ait trois gemmes de montrer
que ça ça peut été édités si oui et
remix de bronze mais mettons c'est comme
ça c'est comme ça que je les
philippiques erna 2015 et mon coup ce
n'est peut-être pas parfait mais si ça
que j'ai fini triet quoi que j'aime de
ceux ci n'ont les tic tac
ça dépend vraiment je dirai at il le
temps de lister c'est quoi ton plat si
tu mets ton justement le plus petit bout
je vais de mai et a tapé le thème pour
de bon c'est quoi le thème pour la
touche avec un clic en a marre des fois
que sa façon de nous préparer je te
dirais c'est peut-être une heure
pas glisser ses doigts genji oui dans ce
sens que ces pots
sa propre journée
dans sept à piedmont tête arrive 3
généralement ça tape est monté six
matches parti faire des choses tout il
ya quelques affaires qui va peut-être
partie comme délogés dans mon studio mel
s être à vos reins
avec moi mais lg c'est d'avoir quelque
chose qui ne bouge pas ouais mais aussi
si jamais mon bras me donne vraiment
souvent je fais des affaires comme très
juste dans mon studio dans différentes
remplacement aura un toit
c'est ce que ça prend plus de temps de
calais at il déjà la route des gens
partent en 2h02 fait qu il québec taq
américains comme quand tu fais sur est
ce que tu vois une différence bâton dans
la réception des gens ce que oui et non
ce qui est
[Musique]
des fois oui des fois non des pauvres et
la vidéo que j'ai eues la semaine
dernière que c'est ce qui me fait pas
avoir à un million j'ai dans mon studio
puis je sais c'est une transition de
lumière genre que je détache pg cheveux
le stic l'éclairage est rouge c'est très
basique c'est ce que j'appelle des
millions de vues qui m'ont aux idéaux
que j'ai fait beaucoup plus
d'investissement attentes déplacer mon
groupe d'abord vraiment moins s'il
fallait
encore une fois on parle de formules qui
essaie vraiment de radio ckoi petit
quand je vais danser pour moi que j'ai
fait des fascistes années de nos studios
j'aime s'échanger des visuels pardon
piemme 6g ferrand pour moi c'est oui
j'imagine que c'est la meilleure façon
de bord sur
la seconde que ça deviens
tu le bien de cette relation qui salue
une obligation si vous laissez là dessus
on parle de trucs vraiment puis ça va
sentir aussi tu puisses y toi ça te
parce que peu importe le succès que si
tous attendent public en mai succèderont
le disque intermittents et on ne sait
pas on sait jamais - en même temps c'est
ça des fois tu essaies de calcul et
mettons le
l'investissement en temps versus le
résultat mais
faut pas le calcul aimant par dessus le
calcul tu vois c'est drôle tout le temps
pour quelque chose qui est qui plus
baiser coin avec un meilleur résultat
mais au final peut-être que tu penses
que ta vidéo est ce qu'il ya un
changement de couleur qui est celle
d'anton studio bones et le monde qui
suivent déjà vont la voir mon à l'écouté
plus mais peut-être aussi que la vidéo
que tu es parti avec les feuilles de
l'automne
d'autres mondes qui vont trouver ses
points
mais si c'était ce sac access calcule
pas en fait faut que je fasse tout selon
ce que toi tu veux vraiment vraiment
c'était pour moi envie gm comme c'est
quelque chose que j'aime varie en
général on ne serait-ce que oui je dis
drôme et justement j'ai fait tellement
d'autres affaires qui touchent pas
jusqu'au drame faille c'est la même
chose quand j'ai envie de changer
d'emplacement peu juste varié ça c'est
vraiment pour moi que j'ai fait
je pense c'est là la clé juste le faire
puis on peut se poser des questions non
plus par pourrait c'est qu'on le met la
vidéo que je ne parlais que vraiment
marchés la semaine dernière
encore une fois c'était jean la plus
spontanée que j'ai fait je pense dans
l'âme ces foules c'est souvent je vais
m'en fous gens réagissent idée quand
j'avais entendu 7 7 9 6 tonnes soit au
ritz et holy dis que tu es netflix je me
suis dit bon je veux juste aller la
partie j'ai fait sur pied voilà c'est
par ici c'est tellement con way
comme ce ph sopi la plupart de monter on
ne refuse municipaux ont eu des
conversations et d'humanité qui ont eu
lieu des succès dans toutes sortes derby
c'est tellement souvent
[Musique]
c'est thomas souvent des hasards talent
belge est faite sous peu me tendant à
rien pu tellement il s'est passé super
c'est comme si j'ai l'impression que
ça ça ça se commande pas outillée padre
c'est vraiment des fois par hasard tu
tombes sur quelque chose au bon moment
puis allemands ni sa les accroches pis
le sacré quelque chose mais c'est
inexplicable
mais c'est pour ça que la pensait que la
recherche du succès est une recherche
inutile
parce que
jamais le contrôle et que tu peux faire
c'est ce que tu veux faire ce que tu
juges qu'il mieux par rapport à tes
propres intérêts et
goût le tuf et soeurs puis après ça tout
prix le succès va être premièrement
succès si c'est pas comparable dans la
haute lesse tout le temps quelque chose
de différent selon son échelle puis
selon tes valeurs mais après si ça va
arriver par soi même ce que tu fais
c'est vrai puisque chez dire ça mais
c'est sûr pour vraiment y ce que tu fais
ça vienne la bonne place c'est fait pour
les bonnes raisons pi du mieux que tu
peux tu peux rien faire d'autre
métissé comme vous j'imagine avec le
podcast
pensez vraiment pas on le faisait parce
qu' on a mis les podcasts pire c'est de
tenter de rencontrer du monde qui jazz
avec 15 autres et puis on le fait encore
pour
encore pour ça
puis après par la musique du temps pour
faire autre chose
faute en ce moment
je prends des marches j'en ai marre
chicoter des amis
mais en fait j'ai quelqu'un qui qui qui
est très proche de sa famille de ses
amis
fax du cactus dans mon temps libre c'est
ce que je fais c'est aussi de voir mon
dire commence à aller voir des shows à
assortir a acté jeudi que je fais rien
mais dans le fond oui j'ai fait du
social c'est surtout le temps de latence
sociable ça me
[Rires]
met en moi la pandémie
dépressif à woippy
si je me suis raccroché justement
amadeus au petit j'aimais tellement se
parlait justement au travers d'un écran
type d'ordre de chapitres se met ça m'a
réellement ebi parce que ça me manque et
je trouvais à trouver le temps quand
même long même si j'étais hyper occupé
mais si j'ai un besoin vital en fait de
jouer de la musique avec des gens de
voir des gens d'aller voir des shows de
ce thé puis au delà de la musique juste
un besoin social très vital
on sait on si tu joues contre une autre
ouais
la première oui
oui j'aime juste d'avoir un flash tout
est ce piège ne ferait un l'interdiction
ouais ouais fait que fait que tu
continues à les voir des shows j'aime le
sport commence
ouais ouais ça me fait rare en débit
moyen du panier en 2009 sur les voir
harmos au lit ah ouais c'est au club
soda même place que lens benoît hamon
puis
j'étais assise puis là il y avait sept
soldats fait qu'il y avait pas de
limites de personnes tout le monde avait
son passeport vaccinale mais pas de
masque les gens les gens à une fois ci
dans la tomate tu te promener tous le
même une fois site internet au mas puis
j'avais l'impression d'être dans la vie
normale monde d'avant avait pas de
charge et j'ai amené j'ai arrêté j'ai
fait c'est juste en train de vivre on
dirait qu on dirait je le voyais
tellement et on dirait que je le voyais
tellement plus loin jetez plus capable
de même visualiser que ça allait déjà ça
allait pouvoir surpasser le puits après
sa sortie les annonces on allait pouvoir
recommencer à danser pierre à
léopard avec mais ton juste les soirées
mettant boudoir musique live
phoenix
avouer que je crois même paul met
totalement raison sam sam a fait ce
feeling parce que je sortis dans
l'ancien comme tant de bord justement tu
montes on passe par l'action d'une
facture en prix c'est comme si
incroyable et comme genre de folie
on était monté à tirer un jour de
quasiment deux ans mais
bonne amie ennemie mais c'est fou comme
maxi précieux times et le con qu'on s'en
rend compte et peut-être pas pour tout
le monde bien
ouais j'ai quand même du monde comme ce
qu'est ça les dérangeait pas trop long
des caves est comme la non obligation
sociale les caisses ne pouvait rester
chez vous il ya quand même des gens
bougent quand même quelqu'un de
solitaire quelque chose que j'ai quand
même aimé là dedans je pense qu'en bout
de ligne la grande majorité du monde on
a quand même besoin
grax concernées a besoin de de proximité
en faisant ses chances nous on a
continué à voir des gens parlent pas de
4ème et sexy s'ils avaient pas lui qu'on
aille pas sûr puisque lotus confesse ça
c'est parce que tout le monde mais qui
sont thomas télétravail qui ne sorte
qu'ils n'avaient plus besoin de sortir
de la maison du genou puis sexy ton
travail c'est la seule connexion humaine
tébessa peu passant par e-mail elle
tente être seul chez vous oui
c'est même moi j'aï ça est un band et
dans des événements sociale ou est ce
qu'il ya vraiment beaucoup de monde le
film fonction sociale mais genre hier je
te lance me lullaby tout le monde me
reconnaissent quand même le tout est
dans le regard des jeunes face à murray
qui se met mal à l'aise de voir que
quelqu'un me regarde pas ce qui c'est
qui me reconnaît maintenant meilleur
temps contador
chic ce genre succès ses magasins sauf
qu'en même temps si je suis content
d'être ici maintenant parce que je vois
tout le monde je parle à des gens
interagissent
je me sens dans un groupe moi si c'est
un homme de quoi des
êtres qui me rassure un peu plus loin
vraiment ça a été particulièrement rude
pour les messieurs en fait le temps que
ça a été
même moi qui ai jamais eu des
questionnements sur comme qui s'est
jetée juges continuent cependant vie est
ce que tu sais comme amener les
questions viennent c'est comme moi
savons tous revenir comme avant puis
c'est beaucoup d'angoissé j'ai pas pour
toi métier moi j'ai l'impression que le
tlm le ca report comme pauvre il dit
si comme il ya plein de monde qui
faisait ce que les fonds puceau pis tu
te rends compte que les écosystèmes a
changé
énormément des personnes qui sont en
fait j'avais d'excellents construction
mes amis de
64 ans qui sont j'ai l'impression qu'on
est avec lui ouais aussi aussi mettez
sont heureux la dame c'est comme était
un vrai col de finalement c'est si c'est
trop instable comme métier puis c'était
je pense qu'on est comme alors je suis
famille
exactement exactement nous remettons
avec le temps tu au dessus
moi mettons j'ai ressenti le besoin de
ralentir un peu le tir parce que j'étais
comme trop au pij justement le rythme
que j'avais deux noms de shb sedan dans
ma vingtaine d'années je peux pas venir
sur tout tout des lots de ralentir ou
pièce que tu fais ou pas vraiment
jardinons baisse parce que je fais je
fais clairement moins de choses graves
en même temps je dîne lg j'emprunte
shooter
c'est quand même beaucoup à tanger même
paquet convient par semaine noté charles
jeu ralentit pas je pense que d'ici les
deux prochains mois mais comme de quoi
du fait que chez moi des fois je
travaille mais c'est que -
c'est tellement intense et quand que tu
fais six heures de charge charritton
drame tout le monde se fait des choses
il ya comme de quoi de tête moins
intense à caen que je faisais de la
tournée je dirais mais je crois que
c'est juste d'avoir un équilibre pour ma
part le sait pas nécessairement de
ralentir d'avoir plus de journées de
congé mais juste peut-être avoir un
horaire comme bon leur bah ouais ouais
c'est souvent way maintenant je dis si
chiffres également comme je l'avais
d'ebita à chaud ah ouais jeanjean
c'était pas trop pour moi de faire un
carton semaines tout le temps que je
tripais vraiment juger si je possède pas
que son stock tout sceptiques 120 en
plus je reste le petit rythme peut-être
tout enjeu cela devra enfin qui laissent
faire cheminer parti shas harris est
vraiment élevé noir les choses
n'ont même pas les analystes ouais
c'est une fois que je pilotais des fois
je pense que c'est difficile de pas
sortir de chez toi c'est quand
j'ai quitté ma sont là des fois une fois
çi rendu au lycée il ya quand même de
quoi qui est ouais j'ai vu quand même
pour ce jeu
peut-être fonctionner
par objectifs et non sa carrière de
joueur je veux pas quitter le type de
chauffe entre la fin ou south est comme
tout le groupe développe il joue son
talent j'ai vraiment goût et de fous
rires main
dessus pour le futur ou
déjà de marston dit où met-on georges
s'est pas dégradée georges je joue écrit
à notre
avis ne m'a plus il faut le jouer avec
la danse
y a comme but bébé des portes qu'avant
je croyais pas qu'ils se pouvait
d'exister mettons que l'eau
tranquillement tg
certaines opportunités fidèles
mais annoncé c'est juste comme je
t'aiderai cuidad de faire les choix
l'international
ce serait mentir parce qu'avec la partie
web que tout dit rien car poche que
on sait jamais
[Musique]
si ça m'était g8 côté
ouais ouais oui
dans les conversations dire non à dawson
j'ai passé puis
j'ai simplement
pensé
[Rires]
aux
dames référence à dire à une scène
delete et de graphisme je vais
maintenant ses 105 ans coupé la finale
c'est comme doit être le tiki qui genre
jim fanning plaisir écrit comme une
scène de la matrice mon fils c'est comme
ça qu'ils le
caecum
morpheus puis le quilleuc la pilule
bleue la paix les rouges qui dit qui
dans matrix qui souffre dans la map il
est fait comme
je me sui sax laquelle qui
met donc c'est la bleue crédit je vais
prendre la route plein guy comme
n'allonge c'est la bleue la cool c'est
elle qui te soutenons
où
[Rires]
est ce que parce que les belges imagine
qu'ils ont une façon votre description
lemay mais ce que les gens te suivre
pour te pour savoir que ce fait
remarquer ce qui s'en vient pour voir
des
plateformes
comme youtube et côté facebook qui
assiste à une plate forme que j'ai
délaissé
c'est dur mais j'étais fois quand je
pensais je publie le mais sincèrement
j'ai pas j'ai dit j'ai ma famille le
pied l'industrie musicale au complet
facebook mais non ça ressemble à ce
peut-être mandat ni twitch ouais ouais
ouais mais ça je les fais des gens
seulement pour 1er
août ali pour ce pigeât j'adore ça en
fait je fais je fais souvent tu sais
combien sort j'ai fait en une heure et
demie de shooter montaut qui étonne que
vous voulez que je fasse que j'aime et
puis je fais je fais tout les toons puis
j'aime vraiment ça va tellement vite qui
ça me fait pratiquer connaître des
nouvelles toute idée d un projecteur de
tout le temps qu'ils jouaient de la
force je connais pas tous les coups
depuis le projet je dirais qu on
le vit ensemble puis je leur montre
aussi des communs c'est ça m'arrive des
fois là d'avoir des geeks
le chanteur record nintendo kindy c'est
quoi ainsi dell dell fille qui t'y pas
que je leur jeu montre aussi comment ce
que je fais normalement pdt de recevoir
un patron de suisse en parlant de
techniques alternatives à temps plein
depuis christian ganja pleuvait dans le
deuxième versement alors aussi factice
est d'adapter ses appareils quand il
n'est pas là la thune facussé sage effet
personne c'est quelque chose qui m'a
toujours fasciné des droits
j'ai joué beaucoup et c'est alex kirouac
puis
on parlait d'une type i think tank
atouts de la gate quintus la magie tout
tenté faute à une des ses colonnes que
ça va rejoindre le major lui le trois
quarts du temps c'est comme le tempo il
ya aujourd'hui urgence et une note comme
aucune de la mélodie c'est quoi
et puis trop c'est quoi à tourner mais
j'en riais joue parfaitement piste
-comme comme s'il avait écouté deux fois
quand même un bel avantage
c'est comme justement le but ou deux
semaines j'ai reçu ce jour une
soixantaine de tonnes ces billets je
pense que ça m'aurait pliait cadre de
temps si justement j'avais je l'aï
taghit pour permettre aux g 6e gémir par
j'ai ma façon de fonctionner et
demi note ddd pour regarder passer au
travers de la thune puis de m'en sortir
c'est mais moi si ça c'est pas ça
différemment de chaque instrument
effectivement l'école depuis on y lit
ceci peut pas rester constamment de
termes en anglais je m'excuse
si ce n'est
pas que par d'autres sinon je n'ai pas
tourné avec damian whitewood autre chose
j'en aurais je refuse que je fais le
baiia plusieurs shows la semaine
prochaine j'aurai 30 en grattant
maintenance et c'est plein plein de
choses différentes qui est je vais
tenter d'avancer sur mes réseaux sociaux
mais souvent j'oublie champ d'ocelote
en fait sa chef à ceux de la promo du
cio tout en 45 minutes
et son
gouvernement samedi artiste à l'artiste
de face mais sais tu vas peut-être
peut-être je me fais tellement demandé
du monde qui veut venir voir mon show
must go on me dit tu donnes simon dans
ma tête c'est ici mais dites à risque
déjà en partant oui c'est très
clairement un clip stich entrepôt outil
aidera bien comme le quad est vraiment
plus si je sais pas comment dire que
c'est ici un peu plus abstrait drôle
mais je pense quand même c'est peut-être
avec un
ouais je pense
avec antichrist a reçu cette somme en
parle de mirage de peut-être le message
que j'aimerais c'est à la carte estime t
il
chanter ou
ça va rester là
j'ai compris c'est plus qu'il faut
qu'elle va débattre toi
ouais ouais on est comme moi ouais mais
les mettons caches découvertes et
chanter comme une campagne
mettez jamais été comme le fn le front
des meilleurs temps en temps je peux ni
la paix ni apporte
une pizzeria
faisait défaut shafak et georges me vois
pas où je me vois du genre f1 il voit
orchidées feuillages bettman et moins de
11 ans je faisais dans les
shops de macquenoise
gens voient que
c'est tellement loin de mes gentils des
fautes
mais je crois que georges faisait
chambre paul prigent
l'acteur jamie king tous ses angles
bien déroulé
ça existe plus il ya plus de vingt patek
de se tester ça car il reste des types
d'accords sur youtube
montrent ian hanson on veut pas chercher
fait tout ce qu'elle aime et on n'en est
pas là fax
et puis tout ttc en classe affaires le
temps déjà mais elles sont maintenant
définies
comme des plantes sur youtube
merci mais non merci à vous deux
de du contenu excellent tu as tout un
pataquès convient
oui
si vous voulez plus de contenu excellent
comme ce que vous venez d'entendre aller
sur le patriote le pitch vous abonner
pour trop de l'or parmi six autres au
delà ouais trois pièces par morlaàs par
mois ils avaient les pattes carte en
avance zac les premiers de votre groupe
d'amis avoir écouter les podcasts qu'ils
allaient avoir pouvoir avoir une avance
quand vous allez tirer la dynamique
entre les amis tout le temps avons une
avance sur les jobs en avance ou des
centres de toi mais avec pétillante une
avance sur l'humanité complète en plus
en plus parce que leur chèque le podcast
su ni voulu nous entendre josé davantage
on fait des encore moins de filtres à
préchac podcast avec là on vient de
finir de tourner le podcast on va en
jaser on va te filer nicole non nicole
il est maintenant évident comme le fit
le travail la place de taza taille est
là mais on jase on parle de conversion
qu'on m'aide à voir mais ce si vous
voulez avoir accès
mais heureusement pour nous
malheureusement pour vous s'est excusé
sur pétule il faut s'abonner abonnez
vous